would you allow your wife to go through
your phone 100 okay
vice versa I think it's ridiculous I
don't think there should be enough trust
with um I don't agree to check in each
of the spawns why
um going behind someone's back breaking
into their phone that's breaking trust
security and you want to create an
insecure relationship I was in a
difficult situation I saw the phone just
had like a child and I was like I am not
touching the phone because I do not know
if I am going to be able to handle
whatever I'm gonna find you're basically
like promoting line
while speaking of the brothers where
they're like yeah I've done that and
then it's caused more problems or maybe
the husband's given a reason to throw
that one because she's confident and
she's 100 like secure around you
of women we have to mention it that
there are those they don't do it but we
need to talk about the majority how
would you feel if you showed your wife a
message of another one message you and
she was like okay
I'll be thinking I don't like
to get you in marital troubles yeah so
if it's the west west it's like you were
out the other day you saw him look at
that girl out of his side it was I I bet
he's got another girl on the side you've
got to look at that phone you will find
that girl in that phone
no
Islam net is raising funds to establish
a Masjid and Community Center in Norway
and they urgently need your support this
donation will be a southern for you
because every person that comes a step
closer to Allah through your donation
you and a child of miraculate click the
link and donate what you can
to your brothers and sisters and dear
friends welcome welcome to another
episode of the
what's the show called
hello don't do this to me the the bitter
truth the bitter truth why is it the
bitter truth
because the truth is bitter the brothers
and sisters we are here to discuss real
issues real topics pertaining to
marriage divorce if you're single
looking to get married whatever it is
inshallah
um and our aim is inshallah to benefit
the Muslim households inshallah so at
the email right here which you can see
you can send in your questions if you're
going through something yourself you
want to join the panel like our dear
esteemed uh sisters honorable sisters or
if you want to come inshallah joint as
brothers please send a email inshallah
and you will get in touch with you when
that happens today's topic is very
interesting because it's pertaining to
marriage and it's pretending to couples
because it's a marriage
um and basically about going through
each other's phones now this is a
phenomenon I think maybe you know
subhanallah so I think personally I
think it's a dangerous thing to do this
me personally I don't know about you
guys but would you allow your wife to go
through your phone 100 okay
vice versa I think it's ridiculous I
don't think there should be enough trust
with
transparency as well yeah but that
question I feel like that you shouldn't
be checking each other's phones they
should be transparency and okay no no no
no no no he said he said would you let
would you let it's not like oh would you
let yeah that's a different question
yeah that's a different question yes but
yeah okay okay so so would you let okay
do you understand uh sister Saul would
you allow or do you think couples are
watching this they should allow each
other to go through each other's um
um at first
I did the mistake of maybe wanting to
access the phone and I think it's really
related to our self-confidence and how
we feel in a couple and that confidence
when you feel like um insecure insecure
in that relationship this is where like
you want to see the phone not because
you're curious not because you want to
invade your husband's life or personal
life but deeply I do not think like
either of them should be checking
anyone's phone first of all as a sister
you ain't checking maybe a sister is
sending me pictures maybe there was non
hijabi or hijabi systems that are there
and I really think that we should keep
saying things private conversation with
my friends conversation with his friends
and I think many times and this has
happened to me
that I was in a difficult situation I
saw the phone
I just had like a child and I was like I
am not touching the phone because I do
not know if I'm gonna be able to handle
um whatever I'm gonna find and I think
this is a pressure that we should is
really like inside work is really inside
healing thinking you know what and Faith
put my trust in Allah if there is
anything that Allah wants to show me
it will show up in the perfect most
honorable way
yeah that's my that's my answer I think
I think it should be a 100 trust with
each other
um I don't agree to check in each of
those forms why
um I think it's a good thing I think
it's a good thing if you are able to do
that but I think it depends on who the
person is themselves as well because
they could see a message it means
something else and they will in their
mind because of the biased thoughts they
have they interpret it into something
else so yes there should be a hundred
percent trust between husbands if your
wife says show me your phone now if the
husband says show me your phone because
they have slight insecurity 100 here but
warn them do not go into my message your
sisters of shared pictures yes or you
know personal conversations if wherever
you have that doubt you check that part
of it but um I don't think it should be
no this is my private space because
um from experience I've been where I've
completely never checked the phone but
that you know what happens sometimes
that person falls into sin
you know and that's where I believe that
trust should lie where husband and wife
if they have that doubt then they should
be able to say to their husband oh why
can I check your form please that's the
only time I believe that okay if there
is doubt then yeah or otherwise no I
don't think there should be a need for
it so your question was should you allow
the person right so that means that
there's a level of trust conversation
happening it's not oh you went to the
bathroom I remember your code and I
snuck onto your phone to look right it
was one of those two one something
behind his back and or her back and the
second is asking so I think there should
be complete transparency between a
husband and a wife I think it should be
done in a healthy and not a toxic way
um and that would be not sneaking in
behind someone's back like if you see
something on your husband's phone and
you're like what was that and you ask
somebody oh who's that from then he
should answer and if he sees something
on your phone you say what was that what
did they want and you should answer you
because as a husband and wife you have
to understand that you each have a
personal life but you are allowed to be
involved in that personal life going
behind someone's back breaking into
their phone that's breaking trust
security and you want to create an
insecure relationship there is exactly
how you do it because you've broken the
foundation that's between you you have
abused their privacy
it's not that and and sharing your
privacy and opening up isn't the same as
losing your privacy because it's done in
a respectful way and so there's two
different kind of ways to go about that
okay interesting so yeah I think it's
like I don't know man like sometimes you
allow like if a problem was allow his
wife to go through the phone yet and
it's like okay you want to be like trust
but I'm speaking of the brothers where
they're like yeah I've done that and
then it's caused more problems he's like
I'll be open and be like you know what
look I don't know for example this
sister messaged me and said she wants to
be my second wife or forever I don't
know oh she's trying to interest yeah
and and I'm being I'm being transparent
imagine the brother saying I'm being
transplant I'm just showing you you know
what I'm not interested at this moment
of time and I'm just showing you well if
you're not gonna be like I appreciate
and I value some people say you know
they start bugging out like oh see why
these girls messaging you I'm really
messing around I'm showing me what
they're saying what's wrong with that no
no no but sometimes sisters can't handle
that bro they don't sometimes I realized
we speak to these brothers this is
better you don't tell your wife because
the more you always like okay why is
girls message uniform why are they
coming to you for your problems yeah but
then again then again how would you feel
how would you feel if you showed your
wife a message of another one message
you and she was like okay
I'll be thinking I don't like I'm not
alone sometimes sometimes sometimes I'll
be a jealousy that bit of you know
something it's kind of good this guy
that's good jealousy that's it healthy
jealousy yeah everyone anyone that
doesn't that's very concerning yeah um
but the thing is that when it goes to
toxic levels where it's like obsessively
like he's messaging you and then every
time you know she's gonna I like it's
like it becomes dangerous and another
thing that we don't understand is that
argument's sake let's suppose so let's
suppose yeah let's suppose the wife or
the husband made a mistake argument say
whatever it may be ugh I don't know I
don't want what if it may be the fact
that you do not know is going to save
your marriage now if you do know it's
going to ruin your marriage it's better
that you do not to know so that's why
some Scholars will say that it's not
forbidden it's forbidden for you to go
through each other's phone because it
can be augmenting let's suppose he went
and got a second wife yeah and arguments
say he was like you know what actually
this is not for me yeah
but he doesn't before you go any going
into it so arguments say give me this
mistake it's better your wife doesn't
know it was a mistake that happened what
if it may be is it better that she comes
and now please or arguments saying vice
versa she message her work
you're basically like promoting line
well to be honest the process allowed
three types of they're called pink lies
yeah or White Lies
um when it comes to War uh when it comes
to in between friends or imagine this
immune you fell out yeah
violated me man no no that was mad yeah
he spoke to me like that and then the
Bible goes you know what but how do you
always talk so much good about you but
you never he said well I was with him
once man was crying but I feel saying
you know at least my boy
and I call you I go bro so this is
something that to reconcile yeah and
then when it comes with uh the um wife
as well yeah you have to like you know
imagine if somebody's wife came and said
oh you know your friend did this and I
thought you know what this guy he always
he cries when I see tears in his eyes
love the guy's in love with you and I've
never seen that in my life in the mirror
he probably hates the guts but the point
is I have to say that to help them
reconciled you get it so it's very
important because otherwise it's going
to go to levels where it becomes
obsessive you don't stop there by the
way yeah it becomes you know since it's
gonna be like the CIA yeah they know
they know everything they go into
something well let you sometimes I don't
know how you guys for the CIA they go
into some Next Level research probably
and they find stuff and I think not only
that also for example there might be
things argument's sake from their past
you don't know maybe it was there they
have no idea I think it ruins marriages
although what do you think okay yeah I
agree yeah
no no attention to what he said in the
first place this is the soul is um
he says like he should be transparency
and everyone should access phones but
that goes no no no no no so so what he
said about what happens in the past you
know that's different for example if you
know if something comes like
let's see he's watching a YouTube video
and that text comes up
and she says who is and you know he's
kind of you know shying away from you
know I'm not going to tell you anything
then I then I agree that there should be
transparency where he should go through
that phone and but for any other cause
just randomly that I I just feel about
the truth if your girl's asking you ever
sorry not your girl stuff for Allah
I'm sorry you know what you mean yeah
yeah so if your wife asks you every day
or like every time you get a text or a
phone call who was that who's that was
that then yeah that's not that's not
really good but like here and there
sometimes she does say oh I see like a
phone dies she goes can I go through
your phone or if she like wants to text
her mum and then she has no connection
and she goes on your phone yeah it's
fine
woman can be very loud you know
what type of women are you talking about
because some women are not like that
some women can accept it okay fair
enough I've seen something and that
could be for two things because she's
confident and she's 100 like secure
around you that's a very nice
but there are some we have to mention it
that there are those they don't do it
but we need to talk about the majority
okay you know what size so what would
you say is that man you're saying that
not a woman
you know what I'm not gonna look at this
yeah because at the end of the day it's
it's hard for about a lot of sisters are
very like
um maybe I'm generalizing but like a lot
of females
that's for many reasons other maybe past
experiences or maybe she's doing
something and then she feels guilty or
maybe the husband's given a reason to
feel that way okay but I'm gonna throw
I'm gonna throw the s word out there
it's the shayateen okay this is the
worst worst to get you in marital
troubles yes and it's the west west is
like you were out the other day you saw
him look at that girl out of his side it
was I I bet he's got another girl on the
side you've got to look at that phone
you will find that girl in that phone
this is the west west it's trying to
destroy your marriage what you need to
say is shaitaan go die thank you very
much I trust my man I know my man you
give yourself if you have a good man why
are you doubting him if he's never given
you a reason to actually think he's
cheating on you where is that coming
from because it's not your thoughts very
good if this is very interesting I'll
speak to brothers who are like from
obviously I can speak to people that I
can vouch for you know I've spent time
with Etc and they could promise what am
I good feeling none of that matching
yeah but still dwives would be like no I
wanna so it comes from because imagine
Yeah because sometimes you don't
understand what shaytan's job is just
imagine bro I'm here all day and I'm
like
I'm not argument another brother yeah
let's call him Ahmed yeah and I go Ahmed
what if your wife talk to someone else I
met your wife maybe you should talk to
someone else bro at one moment at a time
you're gonna be like hey maybe she's
brother brother
24 7 bro man comes in your dreams yeah
and he's telling you all this kind of
stuff so you can see but how do we
tackle that because the what's Is For
Real basically you don't have friends
that's a given but the point is that
shaytan comes and adds different stuff
bro here arguments I don't know
um she goes to I don't know she goes to
work and there's a security I don't know
argument's sake here shaytan bring and
guess what it's spirals but it never
stops at checking the phone bro it
starts following stop putting some
devices in your car you're gonna track
your devices bro it goes to extremes and
we need to read it and I believe not
doing it at car if you're not praying
yeah saying which is very important even
when your Salah it comes you are
supposed to say about Jim
yeah you're supposed to do that okay
maybe next one I think you're crazy but
it's something you have to do it yeah so
we don't implement this and then
is so fundamental if especially if
you're a public figure if you're not
doing it
I'm telling you it's a miracle you're
alive
jealousy envy and all this kind of stuff
but what what could practical solutions
for our sisters or brothers because I
don't know do you think this stands for
more from sisters or brothers like being
nosy like well I think both because they
say what you're mentioning here is
paranoia yes but can we just remind that
the fact that we are talking about
jealousy more than the if if we really
want to talk about something I think
it's more insecurity than jealousy
because there's not an actual fact some
women have reasons like certain like the
brothers said certain husbands behave in
a way or they have maybe a past or maybe
already made mistakes that put the woman
in a very insecure way and I have known
women that were very secure in the
marriage very happy but when that
betrayal happened everything collapsed
this self-confidence it's a inside
destruction and they hate to be like
that they hate to be jealous they hate
to be possessive and be in doubtful they
don't want to be like that but it's the
pain you know it's the pain it's the
trouble I think understandable like even
in their sense even if it's a second
wife because then it's betrayal in it we
understand whether this is coming from
that that is understandable checking the
phone because now you've caused this
whole chaos you're actually using
straight up if you straight up she'll be
like you know what I know if he's going
to do he's going to come and tell me
that's why I tell you a lot of brothers
maybe it's not practical some Scholars
say you should hide it but being open if
I'm gonna get married again I'm going to
come and tell you well like I'm going to
come and tell you you know I want to
come and introduce you to the second
wife yeah so the thing is if you're
honest the woman will say you know what
this guy is a little honest guy is at
least I don't need to go for his phone
is telling me straight up but when you
do it behind the back and then that's
what it causes where I can't trust him
anymore I'm trying to say and even if
you'd be honest you're still going to go
mad anyways ask a question being like
talking to influencers Muslim
influencers how do you deal with that I
always wanted to ask the question with
the woman's communication being married
yourself sliding into DM sliding into
DMS and sometimes they slide it into
audience
it's just like I always wondered how
does it work because obviously you're
talking to the male obviously of the
community but as one of the sisters
topics how does it work brother
you know I mean now we love you we love
you Amina and we're gonna make sure that
no one slides in his DMS
leave them alone
so how do you deal with that I check it
out I don't I don't condone any violence
I'm joking that's a joke no no no
um so when I first started social media
if a girl would comment oh my God you're
so you're so funny I'll say okay thank
you or I'll like double tap the comment
or I said listen I don't like you
replying to the girls and now she
applies to the girls and I'll play three
guys did she reply under your name yes I
was like oh I can't remember when I
can't but it's Mike but it's like my
name and my face on it okay because that
system might be there
yeah but it doesn't matter what doesn't
matter what they think as long as me and
my wife knows who's replying that's the
main things it's nice to say it I think
I think I would really appreciate that
you say it on your accountability that
if and if any comments female comment is
answered it's by my wife and I really
like that policy I think the things to
be honest when it's possible being in
the tower is different because you've
got people messaging you I'm suicidal
I'm in a Haram relationship there are so
it's like we get like we get people we
get sister coming we're not talking
about those sisters no I'm talking about
comments the like the heart a lot of
comments and all that kind of stuff like
yeah like to be honest where they're
sliding the DMs like I want to be your
third wife yeah
very very rarely I never got there yeah
no I'm not joking I'm never good though
you were talking about your true nature
you're going against it of course
they're not going to come in but yeah
but why did nobody think that together
everyone's terrified so the thing is
here is that for example um with me it's
like obviously like we have checks in
place like me let's see you know we have
chicks in place and I think as the
person in the dawa I think it's it's
healthy and not healthy in the same
sense where you allow your wife to have
the access because it for your own good
is good as well number one
and number two sometimes though it's it
can be unhealthy because if your wife is
in a system why are they messaging you
because you should change the other one
dimension why they have to come to you
for doing what I'm trying to say so
these comments are there it's
understandable so it's a thin line so
but you should always I would definitely
say be it somebody that you trust let
them have access to your account because
at least if you keep yourself in check
you have to we're not like we're not
Angels well that is by the mercy of
Allah that we are protected from this I
will never come and give credit to
myself of I do this yes there's
Protocols are taking place but our lives
by Allah like Allah says
that if it wasn't for this one is the
signs that I saw he may have inclined to
it may have so the thing is it goes back
to Allah so Allah like if you have that
good connection with your lord Allah
will protect you but we have to be very
careful sometimes yeah like people
message and with us in public figures
bro people message and they have evil
intentions yeah like back in this world
while I they message you just attract
you just to see ah watch let me see if I
can you know lure him in yeah one lie
and and then actually it's a funny story
I want to talk to the Bible done here
there's one one brother he um he
messaged me
I know I don't know why he did this he
messaged me pretending to be a sister
yeah okay
yeah
he messaged me and he's like he's
talking talking like and it's just he's
saying some stuff and then I just cut
the conversation yeah I just you know
and then he mentioned that yeah it was
me why did you do that yeah and he was
like no he's just like and it's actually
might be hard on for him to do that
because but it's like he was like no
it's good that you replied they knew
they put me in my place but I said still
you know at the end of the day it's it's
imagine I didn't yeah you should expose
myself what I'm trying to say so the
thing is we have to be very very careful
as public figures because at the end of
the day you know we know women are
hypergamous by Nature yeah they look up
for
um men like you are leaders social
influence Etc we have it's a big fit now
it's a big fit now so with us men we
need to be more careful uh because it's
it's you know it's an open challenge but
at the end of the day
um I think going through each other's
phone is unhealthy yeah there might be
those but when you say that you need
context but bro look every day not every
day
we should be like this here nobody's
going through no one's phone yeah
you know what for some reason I've got
this one Whatever it is kind of go
through no problem
there you go at least but now if I do
that and then now it turns me into a
regular stuff now he's like okay look
yeah yeah if I had anything to hide in
that moment yeah and my phone if you see
me always like no don't go in my phone
he's like okay why I'm triggering I'm
causing but if I leave my phone around
everywhere yeah which I do like so there
shouldn't be a reason now where is this
coming from so if it turns into a spiral
of I want to see it no can I check it
out and then you come and catch it look
I'm going through it then it's turned
into it in this and it's going to become
toxic bro I'm trying to say and once
again it might be that she might have
fallen into a sin it might be that you
or me we fell into a sin
it's better that you don't know I Repent
of my Lord it doesn't affect our
marriage what if you see it you don't
need to see it why you don't know it
doesn't harm you so I would personally
say stay away from it it's better to
preserve your marriage because one of
the reasons a lot of people get divorced
yeah I saw this he done this Etc we are
man sometimes we have these issues where
we're like yeah yeah man he's a second
wife Etc and sometimes it's just a phase
they speak and you're like it was just
it's better you don't see it yeah it's
better and I will advise sisters to
protect their mental health yes because
and they should and again we go back to
Dean the fact that you have a strong
relationship with Allah I know it's very
kitch to safety and every time you come
back with that sentence but he will
really really heal the insecurities
inside of you and put your trust in
Allah and like I like what the sister
said actually saying that me being able
to check on my husband's phone is
protecting him as well from the scene
because indirectly you have the fear of
Allah you have the fear of hurting the
person that you love and that loves you
so at sometimes when you a man is weak
yeah a wife yeah a jealous wife yeah can
save you from sins
if anybody feels well sometimes where
you know whatever it may be you know you
you feel like you're gonna fall short
Etc you know what tell your wife you
know what I'll give you fully access to
my passwords all of it do that I think
it's fun definitely protect us at least
you're like you know there's someone
there looking dream I'm trying to say
that falls under that Allah says that we
are like a clothing for each other you
know we are protection for each other we
keep each other accountable not only in
this and everything you're not waking up
for Fajr I'm gonna be your alarm clock
you're not doing this you're slacking on
this that's what we're here for to
counterbalance each other in our
weaknesses I think also like in marriage
when people get married
um they don't get rid of uh male and
female friends so I think the females
don't get rid of their male friends and
the male doesn't get rid of the female
friends yes and then uh
you might be okay about to start which I
don't understand how but you might be
okay with it and then once you you know
get mad you know get married and spend
time and a friend pops up it might be
just an innocent friend but that causes
problems and then you go through the
phone and you you know what I mean bro
that's very dangerous and to be honest
it's a topic within itself so I'm gonna
wrap this up so I promise this I'll be
benefited from this because we're
talking about going through each other's
phone don't do it it's not worth it your
marriage is more important and that's
one of the reasons to do the show uh
till next time
the prophet salallahu said whoever
builds a message for the sake of Allah
Allah will build for him a similar house
in Jannah on that day where Allah tells
us that our books will be given and
every little atom weight of Good Deed
you've done will be there and imagine
you see a mountain and you're like what
a lucky person which righteous person
and Allah says this is for you for me
yes what did I do you allow people to
pray you built a Masjid I never had the
money to build a Masjid Allah you helped
you gave towards it and Allah gives you
the reward of as if you've built it
don't let it now guys and do not delay
and share the video for extra Rewards
[Music]